almost every set of machines that are
just fundamental to the society we've
built here on planet Earth um were
introduced in a different era under a
different set of concerns and
optimization characteristics and now
we're standing here at the pre precipice
of of really powerful artificial
intelligence and we need to be asking
ourselves how might we use um the new
way that technology is changing the
consumer and business intelligence space
to build an infrastructure for our
civilization that is more trustworthy
and trustworthy can be more cyber
secure. It's there when you need it
because it's almost impossible to hack.
um better could be measured in how can
we use
optimization and uh AI control to get
the same level of resources out with
with lower resource inputs and that'll
be lower fuel demands, lower consumption
demands. Um and so there's all different
measures of better that we kind of say
are, you know, we think about in what we
call the brilliant machines thesis.
machines and another generation uh for
for the for this generation that are
secure, reliable, and have a lower
resource
[Music]
footprint. Zack Staples, welcome to 20
milliters. So excited to have you here.
Thank you. Thanks so much. It's great to
be here, Michael. I appreciate the
invite. Super excited to have you here,
Zach.
you know, you're you're dealing with in
in an industry that that I know and
love, obviously, cyber security, but
you're dealing with it in the context of
a little bit different than I'm used to.
And so, I'm really excited to dive into
that and hear your your journey as a
fellow veteran of of a different country
and um and and how you've brought your
your domain expertise and experience
into into this industry. Um and um you
know right before we started here you
said something that that that you you
knew will catch my my attention. You
said you know Michael you know there's
you know there's a lot about integrity
and trust in our work and how do you and
and I and I do get to think a lot about
human trust and what does it mean to
have trust and communication in this in
these interactions and today we're also
going to talk a lot about machine trust
especially in critical environments. So
so Zach welcome to the show. Uh thanks
so much man and and uh you know like you
pointed out um there is uh trust is a
topic with so many different levels
right now. What you're doing with
clarity I think is just absolutely vital
to being able to create and sustain
human trust in the digital age. And um I
think what we're doing at Fathom 5 is
you know similar in the regard that we
think a lot about um establishing
machine trust in the in the digital age
as well. Right. And so what what does
that what does that mean to you? Machine
trust when you say that. Yeah. So kind
of taken at the at the highest level so
we can kind of put everybody um in the
same kind of space, right? There's about
8 billion people in the world right now.
Um it takes an an incredible array of
machines to create the food, water, and
energy necessary to sustain all of those
people. And we need to do it in a
responsible way to sustain the planet,
right? And so when we think about the
generation of machines that we do that
with now, there was never um they were
built under a different engineering
paradigm. And so now we worry about the
cyber security of our electric grids. We
worry about the um integrity and
reliability of our our water um
generation and transportation systems.
you know, almost every set of machines
that are just fundamental to the society
we've built here on planet Earth um were
introduced in a different era under a
different set of concerns and
optimization characteristics. And now
we're standing here at the pre precipice
of of really powerful artificial
intelligence. And we need to be asking
ourselves how might we use um the new
way that technology is changing the
consumer and business intelligence space
to build an infrastructure for our
civilization that is more trustworthy
and trustworthy can be more cyber
secure. It's there when you need it
because it's almost impossible to hack.
um better could be measured in how can
we use
optimization and uh AI control to get
the same level of resources out with
with lower resource inputs and that'll
be lower fuel demands, lower consumption
demands. Um and so there's all different
measures of better that we kind of say
are, you know, we think about in what we
call the brilliant machines thesis.
machines and another generation uh for
for the for this generation that are
secure, reliable and have a lower
resource footprint. So so set the stage
for me because you know we talk a lot
about AI in our day-to-day and we hear a
lot about the advancements that we have
and obviously every person that's here
with us in the show has a has a
smartphone, has a laptop, smart TV. So,
so we we're experiencing this this I
think intuitive consolidation of devices
in our daily life
experiences and we anticipate that these
consolidated devices will become more
and more powerful over time that
software and AI will just self augment
and that same MacBook that I have or
that same Lenovo that I have will just
keep getting better and better on its
own. But we're actually here talking
about a different set of machines that
are powering up a really important parts
of our world. So, so I think it's a
really important framing to just say
that for a second that this is, you
know, there's a whole world of machines
that lives besides our own physical
three devices that we're used to. That's
right. Yeah. Yeah. That's right. You
know, and it's it's super interesting
too in in that regard
because if if you ask most people, you
know, what are the most prevalent
computers in the world, they're going to
kind of go back and forth and some of
them will say it's iPhones, some will
say it's Androids, and and probably most
people won't say laptops, right? But
some might. Um the crazy part is there
are about 5 to 10x more machines
um you know intelligent computerized
systems than those than all of those put
together. So every thermostat in every
building now almost every thermostat in
every home. Think about the number of
computers in a modern automobile. um you
can take that and you can scale it up by
a,000x for the number of computers in a
modern factory and probably another
thousandx for the number of sensors and
computerized machinery controls in a
large industrial facility. So, so the
the fabric of civilization, you know,
the humans interact over those three
devices, but the civilization that makes
all that possible is a layer of
computing and uh and control in the
physical world that's empowered by this
entire other set of machines that most
people never think about. Right. So,
tell me a little bit for a second about
your own your own background or how you
even got here. I'm always fascinated by
by backgrounds and stories. I'm I'm
particularly interested here because uh
you're you're bringing a lot of I think
your personal experience into into the
world that you're doing today. Oh yeah.
Well, thanks for asking. I appreciate
that. So, so I I grew up here in the
United States in Texas and uh I had the
benefit of having a grandfather who had
a farm and and I loved, you know, the
tractors and all all that. And then I
had an opportunity to uh to serve my
country and so was in the Navy for a
while and again kind of big machines. I
served on ships and toward the end of
that I had an opportunity to really get
into electronic and cyber warfare and
start to think through the reliability
of the machines that were both using in
the United States Navy and that were
being used around the world and and came
away from that experience realizing like
we needed to do better like we needed to
do better for national security but we
really needed to do better in providing
a kind of more trustworthy reliable
uh lower resource input machines for the
whole world. And so when I when I
finished my career, I launched Fathom 5
and uh we have uh over the last six or
seven years tried to develop our concept
of brilliant machines with products for
the national security space really just
as a seed funer. you know, the DoD, um,
the US Department of Defense has a long
history of seed funding hard tech, more
so than Silicon Valley has in a long
time. You know, Silicon Valley, I think
you went to Stanford, right? Yeah.
Right. So, yeah. So, you've spent some
time in Silicon Valley. You know,
Silicon Valley for many, many
years, maybe it's changing a little bit,
but has had a strong propensity for
software solutions, solutions that could
scale very quickly in the cloud. there
was such dramatic success with um
consumerf facing products that was
really you know the the the the capital
available to do something new kind of
got isolated into that very narrow space
and so when we launched Fathom 5 in 2018
we looked around and said hey this is
what we want to go do now where is the
best market to get early stage
non-dilutive investment in this and the
and the and the DoD has been a great
partner in that for us and So, we're
really fortunate to have done some
amazing things um for the Navy, but I
think more importantly and more broadly,
you know, we have a suite of
technologies that will be rolling out of
just the national security space and
into the consumer space to go after some
of these broader more uh more impactful
global challenges and machine
resiliency. So I' I'd really love to
understand in in a real world setting
how how um the world how the work that
you're doing is impactful let's say on
on the world of of Navy and Navy ships.
So you know we're looking at the
transformations of AI and software and
hardware and systems and machines. Take
me through a Navy ship. What what
happens there and what what type of work
do you do there? That that's a great
point. You know, lots of people think so
so Fathom 5 was the first company to
deploy artificial intelligence on a on a
naval warship. And so people I I've I've
mentioned that before and gotten the
Terminator question like right after
that. I'm like, "No, that's not what
we're talking about." It turns out the
best way to have a good navy is to put
more ships to sea. It's just so basic,
right? If you have 200 ships or 300
ships and uh and you can only get a
hundred out to sea at a time because of
maintenance and material readiness and
everything else that contributes to
that, then you can then you have an
adversary that only has to build a navy
uh to beat a hundred of your 300 ships.
And so, you know, the the commander of
Fleet Forces Command in in the Navy has
has uh been on the record saying his job
is to change the way we do maintenance
and maintenance planning to get, you
know, 200 plus out to sea. And so, the
first deployment of AI is right in line
with that vision is watch what the
machines are doing and predict the
maintenance that they need. So we can
use, you know, make sure ships are
getting the right maintenance at the
right time with the right parts ready to
go. And we're early in that journey, but
it's a it's it's a such a great space
for AI because it is so inherently safe,
whereas advertising and and eye capture
and all the things we've seen in social
media and other spaces have been, you
know, net detrimental to society and
entire generations. Um, and here you get
and here you get the benefit. Oh, that
m, you know, the machine is the machine
needs the oil change. Let's just go do
that. Yeah. No, absolutely. It's
actually funny. I have a good friend who
who used to run a company called
Nemoata. It's a it's a company that
does AI prediction for um for
um things that need to be done on trucks
for delivery. So yeah, and so I and and
I'm actually an angel investor there
because I really do think that there's a
really huge potential in leveraging
these predictive models to try and and
eliminate a lot of these bottlenecks. In
the case of a truck of a delivery truck,
if it breaks down, then a supermarket
doesn't get groceries. There's business
continuity disruption. In the context of
a Navy ship, if something goes wrong, I
I I don't want to think what what's the
harm in that.
Now, Zach, I have a question. You know
these ships obviously are have a lot of
legacy systems. Yes. I had the the
privilege of also serving in for me 5
years in the IDF and and so I got to
work with a lot of legacy systems and
one of the biggest uh struggles and
tensions naturally have been how do I
take these legacy systems and how do I
get how do I evolve them to these new
generation systems? And generally it
wasn't a okay we're going to take it out
and put something else in but you needed
to think through some kind of some kind
of merge and and and and um a good trend
evolution. So how how do you do that in
in legacy in your world? Yeah, you're
absolutely right. So um
the you know if we if we want to have
this grandio school of making industrial
and defense systems more resilient and
more ready then you just have to accept
as part of that challenge that you it's
got to work for the old stuff not the
new stuff right it's got to it's got to
work for all of it and so you know with
engineering audiences I joke around that
we like to connect uh you know serial
cables to Kubernetes clusters um But
part of that that's that that's why this
is a good space is that there's really
interesting not just grand problems to
solve but fascinating technical
challenges to solve is how how would we
connect the machinery control system
that has all of the you know process
control sensors. How could we build a
cyber secure boundary between that and a
system that makes maintenance
predictions off of those sensors? some
cases the answer is just use the
existing uh you know machinery control
environment that already is getting a
lot of digital feeds. So, I'll just give
you an example for most people's car.
Like most people's car, when you push
down the accelerator pedal, you're
sending a signal to the computer about
how fast you want the car to go. And
then the engine control unit calculates,
okay, what's the fuel mixture to to give
the driver kind of the velocity profile
they asked for, right?
And mixed into that, there's an oxygen
sensor in the exhaust of that car that's
making sure that that fuel air mixture
is right for the temperature and and
atmospheric pressure that you're in to
try and optimize that burn. Um, so
almost every machine, even what we would
call legacy machines, have some amount
of sensors on them because they have
engineering control units, the the
electronic control units for the for the
machine like most cars. So, so going
back 20some years, right, we we still
have ECUs. So, now the question is,
well, how can I hook into that sensor
stream, whether it's on a CAN bus or a
serial bus or or or some sort of
industrial control protocol and then and
then ingest that firewall off so I can't
put signals on the control plane, but
then look at all the data that's
available on the control plane and make
predictive and you know, predictive and
corrective maintenance recommendations
from that data. So the engineering
problems are fascinating. The
opportunity to think about scaling them
for to solve global problems is big. But
yeah, you're right. If you can't do it
on the new if you if you're only good on
the new stuff, then you're not actually
solving the real problem. And so how
much of that is how how much domain
expertise does it require to both
understand the legacy systems,
understand the new possibilities and
then figure out the right methodologies
and plans to make that migration versus
a new a you know a newcomer coming into
the field. You know a lot of people talk
about how in a lot of existing um
existing fields there's opportunities
for new entrepreneurs to come with
completely new frames of mind. you know,
throughout everything we thought about
insurance. Let's reinvent it completely.
Does it work for a national security
type of type of game? Okay, first off,
great question and and I'm I'm glad you
asked that. So, so at Fathom 5, we build
platforms, not AI. So, I have a couple
of projects, but the overall majority of
our projects are platforms for AI in the
national security space, right? And so
the biggest barrier to new entrance in
the national security space was if if I
have a a a you know a tech startup that
is really good at predicting turbine
maintenance, right? We've got a ton of
turbines. We got a ton of rotating
electrical motors, right? So let's say
I've got a I've got a a one, you know,
or somebody out there has a startup that
predicts electric motor health. um you
know in the world past they would have a
really hard time bringing that into the
department of defense because there are
all of these barriers around um them
having to feel the complete system. So
we started off and said hey you know
let's assume that we don't know where
the best artificial intelligence
algorithms for machinery health
predictions are going to come from and
let's really work do all of the wiring
work to build a common data ontology
around all of the incoming sensor feeds.
build a cyber security boundary where we
can tell folks, hey, if you can deploy
in containers like you do in the cloud,
then you can deploy on a warship and and
we'll do some minimizing
uh uh you know tailored security
scanning for your containers, but the
rest of the defense and depth system is
taken care of by the platform. So, so
what we've done is try to be cognizant
that nobody knows who the best AI
providers are going to be. And I'll give
you so I I bend them up into three
categories. There are the um original
equipment
manufacturers, GE, Fairbanks, Morris
Defense, Dresser Rand, go on and on.
People Caterpillar, the people that
actually make the equipment. Then there
are um you know internal scientists that
have been looking at Navy data for uh
you know 20 or 30 years who have tons of
domain experience but they don't build
the equipment. So maybe they're organic
to the organization. And then the third
is third parties um tech startups or
other people who don't build equipment
but have decided to build a
specialization in in predicting
equipment. And you know, one of the
things that we know from AI data is
generally the more data you have, the
better algorithm you can build, right?
And so an OEM usually just has data from
their turbines or their pumps or their
motors. And then you have third parties
who look at every OEM's
uh data in various deployments. And so I
it's still an open it's still an open
ballpark. I don't know who's going to
win that race. Um but it was important
to us to build a platform that enables
all three so a decade from now or two
decades from now winners can emerge.
Yeah. Right. And or or maybe even
sooner.
Yeah. And we're doing some pretty
interesting things now. But yeah, I
think but I think how that plays out,
who can build the best AI for predictive
maintenance is definitely an open
question. Now you you've been you've
been running Fathom 5 for um for quite
some time now. Seven years. Yeah. Yeah.
And so so what what has the last two
years been like for you? Things things
have you know the the the you know the
AI era turning now into the agentic era.
How has that how has your experience
change been different in these last two
years as an entrepreneur founder and CEO
versus the other five? Yeah that's a
great question. So we founded in 2018.
So 2018 to 2020 were a were a very rapid
growth period and then we entered the
global pandemic and I looked around at
my you know my friends and colleagues
and said hey our number one job now is
don't go out of business when when just
about everybody else went out of
business you know in the in the startup
space and so um we were very fortunate
uh Uncle Sam didn't go out of business
and so we kept doing you know whatever
projects brought our way in that was
inside our expertise. The last two or
three years have been equally exciting
because it's been um pairing those off
to get after the vision that inspired us
in the beginning. And so we're we're
super excited about 2025 and 2026. It
was really starting to put the pedal
down on the original vision we had.
Zach, this was so much fun. Thank you so
much for for spending this time with me.
Uh, I think I I I get really excited and
energized about um pro prospective
abilities of taking legacy systems and
turning them into new with new
technology. I think there's so many
opportunities there and it requires a
balance of of patience of of
understanding and appreciation and
respect of what there was as well as a
big appreciation and innovation of of
what's possible to come. And and I think
that all of that together is what makes
for a really exciting opportunity
especially in the AI age where where
there's a bigger I think just a more
general population understanding of
what's possible and that we could do
things differently. It's not just a a
promise an abstract promise. We're
experiencing it in our daily lives and
and hearing how that translates to also
these critical environments is really
great. So thank you for joining me. Hey
my pleasure, Michael. Invite me back
anytime. Love to come back.